you can't nuke a network how would you
nuke Bitcoin you would arm you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
what are the risks inherent in network
State not just the upside which you've
categorized so nicely sure sure I mean
what most people will come to will still
say is oh my God you're so unrealistic
it's never going to work et cetera Etc
and they'll say oh in particular but
people will always come back to you uh
is
um use of force uh oh you know you
inward Army where's the military you
know well you don't have nukes blah blah
and uh you know there's a long and short
answer to that go ahead what no I'm just
laughing I'm nuke so that's that would
be a good thing and uh nowadays right
yeah yeah well the thing is it's
basically something where they're not
actually they're just sort of reacting
at the surface level on something if you
know the reason the internet was
invented in part you know like DARPA
funded it for something that was a
nuclear conflict right exactly that's
right there's resistant and and we might
actually need to go back to that future
where in the event that Putin or
whatever sets off a nuke and the nuclear
taboo is broken you may want to have
governance structures that are nuke
resistant right and you can't nuke a
network how would you nuke that that
actually is something where everybody
you're gonna nuke uh billions of people
that you don't even know where they are
you need to have an XY location and they
need to be implicitly concentrate in one
physical location if you're distributed
that's actually something that makes
nuclear weapons less useful right it's
only if you're sessile and fixed to a
location and you have a lot of fixed
structures and so on and so forth and if
people know where your location is right
so
um you know there's there's a lot of
things where folks haven't really
thought about what just like we talked
about earlier the the cloud geography
versus land geography people have not
thought about what actually security
looks like in an environment where
people are highly mobile or capitalist
mobile where you can encrypt things
where you can distribute and
decentralize things it's not to say that
Force goes away but Force looks a lot
more like drones than nukes you know and
a lot a lot more like you know special
ops than huge armies right and it's much
more Surgical and it's tweezers and it's
you know scalpels it's not sledgehammers
right and so they haven't thought about
what force looks like in a network world
that's not to say that that no Sledge
hammers exist there's still obviously
huge sledgehammers being deployed in
Ukraine and back and forth but a lot of
that is actually also still Cloud War
it's also Network War you know Ukraine
wouldn't be where it is without being
able to wage a really effective Cloud
war against you know Russia's
traditional kind of land War
um
so I think you know you asked what the
downsides are
um I mean that's one downside is is just
that I think uh
which is not exactly what you're asking
but one downside is folks will try to
map those to the things that they have
already seen without thinking about how
technology has changed things it's a
little bit like cryptocurrency a lot
like cryptocurrency where
um it would you know some people get it
right away and for some people they just
have to kind of see it working for a
while so one downside is you just have
to make it work before people believe it
but that's fine I mean you that the
critical thing is for something like
this you don't have to convince
everybody
you just have to convince enough people
that you can get a small percent only a
small percentage of people for example
move to the US that changed the world
you didn't get the majority of people to
assume to even get 10 of the world to
move to us only four percent of the
world is in the US and many of those
were born for folks who moved there
right so tiny percentage moving to the
frontier can change everything so in a
sense the quote lack of majority appeal
or what have you you know is actually is
it bad it's actually good in some ways
this was just a teaser
to make sure you don't miss the full
episode of biology click here and
subscribe and don't forget to hit the
notification Bell
[Music]
[Music]